Nhưng như thế này, tuyệt vui cũng có thích ra vui
Hãy bởi vì mình chất mai nữan
đã tỏa sang bên này
Tỏa đồng
ở nhà
Chờ
Mà sang ai
Mói lên ăn một mình mà đá trước nước lâu
Phong sau để chảy vào
Tùi uo khoảng 2 hửa trong khoảng 2 hửa
Hãy cho con chút ở nhà
Tỏa ui thứ mà chút ở những hủ rời
Hửa làm vứa làm vứa làm gì
Em mình làm lại
E tỏa đỡi thích nổi hình dập hi
Tỏa xin rất bận lạnh gì
Còn này là ăn mà
Hãy tỏa ăn để tỏa ở ý
thì mình thấy nó là đúng cái tiền úi tình này
Chính sở.
Chính sở rất dân đi thì nó ngon quán khiển
Mình ở rất dồi này mình chỉ bây giờ chỉ cần chứ quà
Mình ở cóm gái thì nó tình dạc nó lớn ngon
ở có chói khác thích thích bói hãy đưa
mấy ông vạn và gồm vẻ mình bảo như ông sạn
để giảm mạnh thế quên Vô này vẫn thể làm quá
thế đâu